hello everyone
in this video we'll discuss how to
optimize your kubernetes clusters and
workloads in a cost-effective way
without compromising the performance and
reliability of your workloads
the content creator for this video is
Samara Casa who is a technical account
manager for Google Cloud
he curated the information for you to
have a deeper understanding of
optimizing your kubernetes clusters and
workloads for reliability and cost
efficiency let's Dive In
cost optimization is commonly
misinterpreted as a one-time process
focused on reducing costs
however it is an ongoing Journey that
needs to be constantly reviewed and
updated
building a cost optimization culture and
routine into your organization can help
you balance performance reliability and
cost this in turn will give your team
and business a Competitive Edge helping
you focus on innovation
the better the team understands the
challenges consequences and best
practices related to cost optimization
the better the cost savings will be
however executing cost optimization
recommendations has proven to be
challenging especially when Cloud native
platforms such as kubernetes are taken
into account
many teams have not worked with
pay-as-you-go services so they may not
be familiar with how resource allocation
demand-based scaling and application
deployment processes can affect their
costs
for example resource waste caused by
over-provisioning clusters and workloads
without considering the actual needs of
an application
application reliability and performance
issues due to not setting the resource
requests or setting them too small
and the inability to scale down
kubernetes clusters due to workloads or
cluster configurations that block
cluster Auto scaling
these are just some of the issues our
customers frequently encounter and they
are great opportunities to control costs
overcoming these issues can be
challenging especially in kubernetes
because kubernetes is a complex
distributed system with many features
and when used incorrectly it can lead to
reliability and performance issues and
increased costs
but don't worry after several years of
iterating over numerous metrics and
feedback from our customer engagements
we have identified the golden signals
that allow you to continuously deliver
business value by running reliable
performant and cost efficient
applications on kubernetes clusters on
any Cloud platform the golden signals
are divided into two categories
resources and discounts
app developers and platform
administrators are responsible for the
resource optimizations while platform
administrators and budget owners are
responsible for the discount
optimizations note that roles within
each organization May differ
the first signal in the resource
category is workload right sizing
workload right sizing is comparing
requested resources to actual
utilization and understanding whether
developers are using the resources they
requested for their applications
these steps ensure that the resources
aren't over or under provisioned to
reduce resource waste and avoid
intermittent issues with performance and
reliability resource requests must be
set appropriately by understanding your
application capacity requirements
the second signal is scaling down the
cluster during off-peak hours to save
money during low demand periods such as
night time or during times of the day
where traffic to your application is
lower your clusters should be able to
scale down with demand it is important
to remember that scaling down a cluster
is a shared responsibility between
developers and platform teams if
developers don't scale down their
workloads platform team's ability to
scale down a cluster is limited on the
other hand if developers manage to scale
down their workloads during off-peak
hours platform admins can fine tune the
cluster Auto scaling properties to meet
application demand
the third golden signal is bin packing
bin packing is making sure you're
requesting the appropriate machine type
and properly packing the pods deployed
in your environment
cluster bin packing is another shared
responsibility between developers and
platform teams where both should
collaborate to find the appropriate
machine shape to better fit the
workloads
last but not least discounts most of the
public Cloud providers offer spot VMS
and continuous use discount options
adopting these pricing models will offer
significant cost reductions to your
kubernetes clusters
you now know the four golden signals for
running reliable performant and cost
efficient applications on kubernetes
clusters
we hope you found this video helpful
check out the links in the description
to learn more about optimizing your
kubernetes workloads on gke clusters in
other videos you learn about the
importance of setting appropriate
resource requests for workloads and how
to right size your workloads thanks for
watching
to learn more check out our special
report on the state of kubernetes cost
optimization which is a cloud agnostic
quantitative research study based on
anonymized real-world usage data the
report examines how kubernetes
capabilities and signals can help
identify key areas you should prioritize
to achieve greater reliability and cost
efficiency check the description for the
link